then she has she gets pregnant and she
has twins and this is an interesting
thing the twins fight inside her she can
tell that that they're not getting along
and this is an echo right it's an echo
of Cain and Abel and there's a
mythological motif that the unions have
called the hostile brothers the hostile
brothers and you see them all the time
Batman and the Joker or hostile brothers
and Thor and Loki or hostile brothers
and it's an unbelievably common motif
and you know the ultimate hostile
brothers are Christ and Satan so that's
the that's the archetypal representation
of the hostile brothers right the
ultimate good and the ultimate evil and
so and so it's an echo of the cain and
abel story although it's a little more
complex I would say from a literary
point of view because it isn't obvious
which of these brothers is Cain and
which of them is Abel they have parts of
both in each of them so Esau who turns
out to be one of the brothers in Jacob
who turns out to be the other both have
their admirable qualities and their
faults
anyways Esau comes is born first
but Jacob has him by the heel and so
there was a fight within the womb to see
who would emerge first now that's
relevant because the firstborn had a
special status well has a special status
in many communities especially
agricultural communities and there's a
reason all these people were more herds
people but if you divide your property
equally among all your children then in
like three generations everybody has one
goat and everybody starves to death you
know or the same thing happens with
lands so one of the ways that the
traditional communities solve that is
they just give them almost everything to
the firstborn and then everyone else
knows well you go out and do whatever
you can and it's kind of arbitrary and
unfair but you know at least it's
predictably arbitrary and unfair
instead of doom over for generations you
know so it actually mattered to be the
firstborn and and God generally favors
the firstborn and then you might think
well what is it about being born first
that's so relevant apart from the the
cultural practice of more generous
inheritance and I would say well the
firstborn is
something like the model for the leader
of the family right because the
firstborn child should be if there's a
number of siblings they should take care
of the siblings at least to some degree
but also should be a role model for them
so it's like a natural position of
leadership but there's a sight there's a
cycle psychologize ation of the idea of
the first board in these stories because
god often passes over the firstborn in
favor of a later born child he seems to
do that on the basis of moral character
essentially and so there's this idea
that well there's a natural proclivity
towards leadership that's just a
biological fact that would be associated
with being a firstborn but there's a
element of characterological development
that transcends that and so that you
it's more important to be spiritually a
firstborn let's say than to be
biologically a firstborn and God
recognizes that continually in these
stories and inverts the natural order
and favors a later born who's who's done
more work with regards to
characterological development